ouais ouais
deux hommes m'ont répondu à son livre
mangas ses dessins
oui allô oui si vous voulez on pas les
dîners ailleurs aussi un c'est gérald
avec ses deux nièces
françoise et amanda après tu serais pas
mandat lire par hasard oui et c'est pas
par hasard ça te fait courette rencontre
et ont tout plein ça m'est déjà arrivé
je au cours de certains de mes confrères
les deux premiers rangs sont plaints de
sosies d'amande à lire mais genre dans
un miroir déformant traficoter un petit
peu la charge et c'était que ça fait un
peu peur je trouves tu ne trouves
comment mieux qu'à la télé oui puis à
l'odeur il ya ce partout frein en deux
temps c'est mieux je trouve en vrai donc
étoiles matin quand il te regarde dans
la glace a tu trouves comment tu fais
avec difficulté non parce que le matin
c'est vrai j'ai les yeux qui sont pas
tout à fait ouverts et quand finalement
je me trouve c'est un petit peu un choc
et puis après on s'habitue temps quand
tu étais tout petits torés mais
ressemble bien qu i am et l'ouest
j'adorerais mais ouest cette auto ironie
ce sens à dérision sens de l'humour
dédramatiser aussi le sexe ça me
plaisait beaucoup et puis après je les
rencontre et ça continue nettement idole
mais beaucoup pas à moi non non pas
vraiment c'était pas mon nom c'était pas
du tout le genre de personne qui me
plaisait qui m'attire et qu'ils fassent
ils citent ya vu une baguette magique tu
changerais quoi en toi rien rien n'a
changé et rien acheter tout bien
maintenant et content d'elle
et qu'est ce que tu as de plus sexy mon
cul de l'avis général le même clou se
feraient l'amour avec moi à fécamp
beaucoup de contraintes
il faudrait vraiment m'y obligeait et
peut-être me donner des sous en plus et
si tu étais bien payé tu t'y prendre et
comment au jeu fermeraient les yeux et
je penserai quelqu'un d'autre je pense
que c'est ce que je ferai xo fort à très
bien c'est bon à savoir tu m'aimes un
peu quand même
il ya beaucoup d'amour il ya beaucoup de
ncc conflictuelle
c'est difficile de lire les quelqu'un
comme toi
comment va mon savoir
voilà étaient mignons petits cochons un
bien tu es né à hong kong
oui d'un père marin oui bree tanner du
nu britannique et d'une mère divorcée
oui et ce qui est élevé à nice dans la
haine des hommes
faut te dire qu'au départ j'étais quand
même assez moche ah bon oui parce que
c'est arrangé comme en service militaire
non si je portais un appareil pour
redresser les dents si j'avais les dents
qui avançaient et à l'évidence et
c'était moche c'est sûr que je souriais
j'avais des fils de fer dans tous les
sens ça existe encore et puis j'étais
trop grande et j'étais trop maigre et
donc c'était plutôt loppement que moi je
trouver moche et puis j'ai de la chance
d'être à une époque l'époque françoise
hardy et sait où on cherchait justement
des mannequins c'était paco rabanne qui
m'avait demandé des filets non non le
fil de fer étaient partis mais je dire
le côté grande bringue deon grant peu
maigrichonne m'a servi et comment t'es
tu retrouvé à londres dans les années 60
dans le swinging london irish
oui alors ça c'est
c'est bizarre quand tu penses que j'ai
connu ça tu sais je parle à des gamins
anglais maintenant et il me regarde avec
des yeux comme ça mais vous avez
vraiment connu jones jimi hendrix et jon
leyne et j'ai l'impression d'être un
dinosaure surtees a intimement connu oui
j'ai voté une cité cinq noms tu vas me
dire ce que tu as intimement connu
intimement publiquement avec la langue
alors oui
alors allons-y jimi hendrix jimi hendrix
était un copain il habitait à la maison
où rien de sexuel n'est pas couché on
aura un jour un pub parce qu'il aimait
assez il avait une certaine faiblesse
pour les blondes décolorées mais si rien
passé john lennon non bryan ferry
oui et alors
et alors quoi je sais pas il est effet
comme nous intéresse
rien de pire et c'est très curieux tu
sais il m'a il m'a demandé de poser pour
une pochette de disque comme ça que ça
s'est passé il m'avait vu défiler à
londres et il avait besoin d'une fille
pour sa nouvelle pochette de disque il
soit un petit peu dominatrix maîtresse
dominatrice qui est un peu sado maso et
donc comme il aimait beaucoup ça il m'a
flanqué des talons comme ça cuir noir
chignon et il veut une grand mère noire
en l'est de l'île oui oui oui c'est des
cuirs des clips maintenant quand on avec
l'ensemble c'était mieux ou moins bien
c'était plus imaginatifs
brian jones oui oui si brian jones il
est habité un certain moment à la maison
mais c'est très beau mais incapable de
faire quoi que ce soit il était quand
même très il avait plutôt besoin disons
d'une maman de tendresse d'une
infirmière plutôt que d'une maîtresse
était pas et salvador dali tu le
rencontres et comment ma vie arriver
chez castel
il était assis entouré d'une cour comme
toujours et il a voulu me connaître et
il m'a dit ah vous savez vous avez la
plus belle tête de mort que j'ai baptisé
tout fait deux morts moi comme si bien
accueilli et tout exprès tu as vécu 15
ans avec lui plus oui presque 18 mai des
mariés oui et alors je sais jamais
merveilleux avec sa femme
ah bon parce que tu vois là alors ghana
est le genre de femme ou été que
j'aimerais être et que je pense toutes
les femmes aimeraient être
c'est le genre de femme qui dit si vous
êtes si mon mari est heureux avec vous
vous m avez l'édiction je veux mon mari
soit heureux ici j'aime mon mari je sais
tout pour moi et donc si mon mari et
aurez vous et venez habiter à la maison
citoyens sont ouverts mais super jalouse
quand tu arrives et le parti en voyage
et c'est même un gabarit
mais revêt un mot dix vingt dix vraiment
c'était comme à la cour de louis xiv
nous en rendrons sauront trouver des
machins à l'arrivée non j'arrivais
immédiatement elle se trouvait
brusquement une urgence help elle devait
partir en voyage elle revenait au bout
d'un mois l'aller en grèce ou en suisse
elle revenait pour ça qu au moins sont
là justement je devais rentrer à londres
donc c'était on se croise et ont passé
quand même deux trois jours ensemble
pour que la bonne harmonie règne et 7
est formidable et dali j'te jure que
dali après avoir passé trois mois avec
moi l'été il est tombé dans les bras de
sa femme à lui manquer ils étaient
contents de la revois d'elle c'était
quoi qui lui plaisait chez toi faut côté
androgyne
non c'était autre chose c'était il me
voyez venir à bly savais que j'avais
souffert que j'étais angoissé quoi mais
j'étais très angoissée d'ailleurs je
suis encore très très violent de
vulnérabilité est ce que tu as souffert
de cette rumeur qui a couru sur ton
compte
disons que tu étais un transsexuel pas
du tout j'ai j'ai souffert nous
embrassions moi c'est pas vrai s'est
s'offert le jour où j'ai fait des photos
à poil très belle d'ailleurs dans un
journal de messieurs et puis je me suis
marié et cera et à ce moment là j'ai
reçu des lettres et moins croyant avoir
bien fait on fait ces photos pour
rassurer mon cher public sur ce délai de
dix ans mais pourquoi vous avez fait ça
mais qu'est ce qu'on est déçus mais nous
on ose espérer imaginer que peut-être
vous étiez référent des habitants ils
étaient franchement déçu j'ai perdu
plein de fans parce que on croyait qu
amanda lear c'était justement pas comme
toutes les autres bonnes femmes et donc
ça ça m'a fait de la peine d'un seul
gène et sociales et un mandat que ces
photos il ya des spécialistes qu'ils ont
agrandi cui pour regarder la diplomation
déploie au regard des scellés joël
planté comme un an
rien on les italiens les italiens italie
l'italien aura grandi les photos pour
regarder dans quel sens pousser mes
poils tu vas tu aurais pu pour prouver
définitivement que tu n'étais pas un
homme à la demie de faire un enfant
comme celle là
non c'est pas c'est pas une chose qui me
tente de tabourets franchement je
pourrais même en adopter à en acheter un
si je pouvais pas en avoir je trouve que
dans le métier que nous faisons en fait
pas d'enfant on est des monstres au nez
des personnes épouvantable mais en fait
tu as laissé quand même courir le bruit
parce que ça te faisait de la pub ça m'a
fait vendre beaucoup de disques
dalli qui t'a mis à la peinture et
pourtant ils disaient les femmes
pourront jamais prendre parce qu'elles
n'ont pas de testicules oui voila je
peignais avant de rencontrer je lui ai
dit vous savez je fais de la peinture je
sais tout contente
il m'a dit quelle horreur une femme
peintre et des traits et très méchant
vous ayez des femmes peindre il disait
qu'elle n'avait aucun talent parce que
le talent réside et exclusivement dans
les couilles tu vois
ensuite amendé tu t'es tu t'es marié
avec alain philippe de malaria a lancé
durant combien de temps ça ça n'a pas
duré longtemps parce que on s'est marié
à mardi et je voulait divorcer un
vendredi sans toutefois y est pour
berlusconi envie que la vie il ya entre
vous n'y a pas juste c'est terrible
parce que oui entre au bout tu as tu
commencé
moi si j'avais l'impression que les gens
il ya des gens qui vient d'y aller on
sait que vous êtes madame berlusconi
enfin vous n'y pensez pas vous allez on
sait et alors cette chose était
insultant parce que ça voudrait dire que
je bosse ouais parce que je couche avec
le monde il est gentil et que si je sais
pas avec lui j'ai passé talent pour
animer une émission
bon tu couches quand même pas avec qui
c'est le directeur des programmes
oui bon c'est se dire dans notre métier
ce mois je sais que tout le monde il
faut coucher moi je sais pas personne ne
l'a jamais de mal à passer
je travaille pour berlusconi c'est une
émission quotidienne c'est une émission
que tu révises et sa non c'était l'an
dernier j'avais une émission où j'étais
dans un grand lit des draps en satin et
je recevais mes invités en pyjama
j'avais beaucoup d'hommes politiques
beaucoup de sportifs actrice cinéma
c'était très amusant d'être en pyjama et
c'était des confidences qu'on se faisait
sur laurier cette année dans cette année
c'est une émission de variétés où on est
très paillettes strass papillon et tous
plus glee mais l'émission au lit je
crois qu'on va peut-être en un projet
pour la france mais est ce que nos
hommes politiques voudront venir au lit
avec mais bien sûr
boissons et jusqu'à ce que tu crois pas
qu'il aurait travaillé sur une chaîne
sexy une chaîne qui diffuse que du sexy
non parce que tu sais le sexy sinon
c'est pas ma spécialité voix canton en
italie on considère comme un symbole
sexuel je suis sûr que pour moi c'est un
mystère
parce que pour moi la femme sexy
italienne bon ccc c'est une brune bien
trop cher et plein de poils sous les
bras je ne sais pas tu vas grande blonde
et errer comme ça tu veux voir la chaîne
sexy la quelle chaîne extra garde
rencontre a été annoncée pas les pouces
depuis le décollage en décembre 88 de
cette fusée ariane le satellite
luxembourgeois astra a fait du chemin
sur son orbite géostationnaire à 36
mille kilomètres de la terre
il diffuse vers toute l'europe une
trentaine de chaînes de télévision
depuis le 15 décembre dernier le canal
22 d'astra est occupé par une chaîne
italienne d'un genre un peu particulier
sexy sat la première chaîne érotique par
satellite
jean est à l'essai crise à l'originalité
de sexy 7 cd m 24 heures sur 24
la journée nous diffusion des émissions
de charme châble et la nuit des films
plus hard mais beau tout de même pour
ses programmes
il y a cinq sont simultanés le français
a su rassembler et l'allemand l'espagnol
et l'italien
sexy 7 est une cham est réputé pour cent
trente ans par mois soit 19 véhicules
les français pourront à partir du 15
avril prochain recevoir une carte
d'accès bien sûr il leur faudra aussi
posséder l' équipement de réception
satellite
[Musique]
et
pour recevoir sexy 7 aujourd'hui vous
suffit d'avoir un ensemble satellites de
type astra dans le prix tourne aux
alentours de 4000 francs qui comprend un
récepteur satellite une antenne de 60 cm
et le décodeur vous introduisez votre
carte dans le décodeur de type vidéo
crypte on introduit est tout simplement
l'image par yves concernant la directive
européenne sur l'audiovisuel sexy 7 ne
fait pas dans la dentelle la diffusion
de films érotiques ou pornographiques 24
heures sur 24 est le seul cahier des
charges qui s'impose la chaîne milanaise
c'est ça n'est compétent que sur le
territoire français ne peut pas
s'opposer à la diffusion des ondes qui
viennent du ciel et donc des ongles qui
viennent par satellite
de plus en ce qui concerne les cartes
d'abonnement le csa ne peut pas mettre
du tout son nez dans la
commercialisation de cartes qui viennent
d'un territoire européen
vous savez que le roc de 93 va permettre
la commercialisation de tous les
produits à travers tous les pays
européens que le csa sera sur un certain
kutxa d'oeuvre française sera tout de
même respecté il voulait te demander si
tu pouvais me préparer une camomille je
reviens de la gymnastique
je me sens un petit peu tendu j'arrive
pas à dormir
bien qu une chaîne érotique européenne s
de l'info est de l'intox
amanda lear à l'oreille généreux qui
connaissent de l'info ou de l'intox
d'arrêter à toi de jouer at works
tu crois pas pourquoi est ce que j'ai
une tête à croire au sexe tant que
ceux-ci abadie dont pourquoi pas déjà il
s'interdit tellement beau de choses que
je ne crois pas que ils vont permettre
des trucs un peu comme ça c'est que ça
ment oui oui ben abondamment dit aussi
que c'était de l'intox un truc c'est de
l'intox en effet parce que devant chalon
n'ont jamais entendu parler il ya une
chaîne sexy en italie mais ça peut être
pas tant elle s'appelle comment ça
s'appelle colpo grosso et c'est sur l'a7
c'est mieux qu'en france alors là c'est
bon on va savoir ce qu'on dit l'expert
philippe guérin
bonnet darmanté philippe ah oui mon
petit thierry j'aime réfugiés tout de
suite sur le 36 15 codes à deux puisque
comme tu le sais à partir de maintenant
vous pouvez savoir les résultats les
pourcentages des gens qui ont répondu
infos et des gens qui ont répondu un
autre à mon avis là vous devez être 90%
sur le minitel avoir répondu un faux
puisque c'est de l'intox
sinon oui mon petit ardi sous c'est de
l'intox mais là sur cette question on a
été un petit peu vache à mon avis parce
qu'une chaîne par satellite érotique
européenne ce n'est plus qu'une question
de semaines avant de devenir de l'info
j'ai dit par satellite parce que par
câble à mon avis les habitants
d'asnières vont attendre un petit peu
avant d'avoir composé pendant des années
le 22 sur leurs cadrans téléphonique de
pouvoir composer le 69 sur leur
télécommande
gamin je te demande à rien je t'écoute
pour ce qui est du square mandat peu
fier de lui car il a fait aussi bien que
les deux sosies 1 partent au bagout
demande a été très heureux de t'avoir ce
soit avec nous on va te laisse y
retourner en italie
oui c'est vrai que je repars n'y avait
que berlusconi aura définitivement l'a5
je lui souhaite le pauvre il y tient
tellement on espère que tu auras le 20h
alors dis-moi amende à riccione avec tf1
à bages ans filles genre je répète
dernière fois qu'on le voit sur france 2
parce que après tout ça une serveuse ben
oui c'est curieux que j'étais en italie
j'ai une émission la barre la radio et
ils m'ont téléphoné qu'ils avaient pensé
à moi pour présenter cette grande
émission du samedi soir et dont j'ai été
surprise parce que je dis pourquoi moi
c'est finalement canton il faut croire
que il voulait reformer un couple un
couple célèbre c'est à dire christian
morin amanda lear on avait lancé la 5
savez bon marché
on est gros et ça n'a marché que quand
on y était oui quand on s'est arrêté que
c'est vrai moi ça n'a plus marché donc
je retiens vente voilà
et donc ils veulent réformer ce couple
enquête on sent un coup plein d'humour
d'ironie et voilà alors j'ai été très
surprise et puis maintenant le le choc
passé je dis pourquoi pas oui bien sûr
samedi soir j'ai rien à faire un jean
berthon plus sans arrêt non plus alors
dis-moi comment tu fais un chaud et doux
pour berlusconi c'est ça non en ce
moment je travaille pour la rai banda et
pour la rage c'est un show quotidien
tous les matins la radio et là les gens
de toute l'italie téléphone et tous les
matins on parle de tout de détaxe des
élections américaines des impôts de la
mafia de tout ce que tu veux et les gens
m'appellent en direct et je trouve ça
tellement grisant excitant d'avoir
vraiment l'opinion publique du voix du
fin fond de la cale un du genre on
assassine m'appelle et là il n'y a pas
de filtrage temps de m'appeler me dire
des horreurs d'ailleurs tous les matins
je me dis chouette on va peut-être 1
et puis non finalement ça se passe
tellement ils sont comment les italiens
en ce moment et c'est vrai cette cette
division entre jusqu'à 10 du nord il ya
le sud ça a vraiment élevé la fameuse
digues et ça c'est grave parce que c'est
impossible de diviser l'italie dans les
jeux c'est comme si on faisait une ligne
qui s'arrête à lyon tu vois les gens ici
dix ans car on ne le savait pas marché
ça faisait et puis en plus non il ya des
vilaines choses qui se passent un
italien en ce moment il ya un renouveau
du racisme il ya des problèmes
économiques
tous les tous les hommes politiques sont
sont arrêtés pour des histoires de
pots-de-vin des affaires sans arrêt
je suis aussi mais les arêtes poste
alors un italie bon ça va mal et moi ce
qui me touche le plus c'est que la lire
italienne et beaucoup tomber alors tu
reviens un peu il ya lieu d feront quoi
bas ne sont pas terribles efron en plus
ans à bonbons fondateur qu'on s'en
sortira moi j'ai vu des voyantes
récemment par elisabeth tessier mais
d'autres qui m'ont dit que ça on n'était
pas sorti de la mère de la banque dit
laurianne robin nous attendons toute
l'année qui vient là il ya avant
l'économie tout ça il va falloir
s'accrocher au moins une émission alors
même si la wii on bosse et l'émission de
paul je mets beaucoup à des quantités
olivier wyssa des grand sahara qui est
ce utopique évident et ça lui a pas
réussi du tout mais oui il avait piqué
l'idée d'un je lui ai dit il doit pas
payer pour ça ben non mais pour se faire
pardonner il m'avait invité à faire sa
dernière émission et il voulait
justement faire un grand match a montré
un truc au lit de financement s'est
passé parce que le pôle ans est arrêté
il n'a pas montré cette émission tu
recevais les gens là moi j'aurais aimé
qu'il amont aval avant que les abc choix
qui la prends ton petit téléviseur
prenez votre petit téléviseur on va voir
amanda recevant les gens au lit voilà
c'était dans un bolide sapin
mystérieux et sa mère
son hobby en mêlant profond - n
tout le monde trop salamya mois
muji 1
on a tenté
et toi nous colle ici
tha
l'état
non
et demi
si caen
conte
tu vois
oh
tous
m
les hommes politiques les footballeurs
tout le monde est accepté de venir dans
le lit d'un game mois et puis il faut
qu'ils aient dans le livre était
paralysée terreur il
ils se disent qu'est ce que je fous là
qu'est ce que je fous là alors c'est
très curieux ils venaient parce qu'il y
avait une vieille libido tu vois l'idée
d'aller au lit avec un mandat lire puis
après un sévère blanche et qu'est ce qui
se passe encore mais le public en soit
il est confiant le yoshi soutien du de
fumer c'est un lieu public
oui mais c'est un lieu public depuis le
début vous en train de lui je vais dire
l'argent prise de tête
bon rantanplan des gentils du kof
trois vols à bas vraiment bon enfin on
va passer à l'interview première fois
est ce que tu es prête
amanda première fois première fois
premier souvenir marchande pas deux
premiers souvenirs je suis pas deux
premiers segments c'est vrai et promet
surtout quand on est tout petit à petit
le biberon je sais pas les billets
pourront quand même ou le biberon
pour une seule premier choc un premier
choc quand on m'a appelé
on y arrivera jasmin le wi fi non un
sacha une purge rire angers ce que
j'avais des premières fois où tu étais
retrouver toute nue avec un garçon et
par l'armée
non non ben csba c'est moche quand elle
après celle ci fais pas ça parce que
j'avais beaucoup idéalisé tout cela je
le voyais un peu comme lui la wii tout
liste um harmonieux et ses jantes en
oman 1
et puis on se retrouve avec un mec
poilus première expérience homosexuelle
hamon alors très mauvaise qualité
ah bon moi je suis une très mauvaise
lesbienne c'est même pas la peine que
j'insiste ne rien faire je laisse faire
dans ses premières expériences à
plusieurs là c'est pareil parce que
c'est pas mon truc j'aime bien je suis
un peu égoïste au lit alors j'aime bien
qu'on s'occupe de moi tout seul alors je
veux partager avec des copines et puis
attendre son tour et tout ça ça premier
mariage oui ton premier mariage trois
jours ah oui
non ça c'est la ruée cette alarme et
laurent ces trois jours mais ces trois
heures notre jeu ou trois jours avec mon
premier mariage c'était c'était un coup
de tête comme ça il m'a lubie une folie
je me voyais madame et puis après les
études mère je suis madame qu'elles ont
horreur on y va premier geste le matin
entre ríos bat les couilles
que serait que le premier geste en me
réveillant je me lève je vais dans la
salle de bain je me regarde dans la
glace je me dis oui et je me dis qu est
ce que je suis belle qu'est-ce que je
suis bien que ceux ci bien même si c'est
pas vrai même si je trouve que j'ai
l'oeil bouffier tout qu'est-ce que je
suis bien c'est devenu une habitude
c'est très important ça fait partie je
te l'expliquerai de ma méthode de pensée
positive
quelle serait ta dernière volonté si tu
devais mourir là maintenant il tout de
suite suite à main là maintenant quelle
serait ta dernière n'oublie pas de
nourrir ma chatte parce que
auparavant c'est très dur
écoutez ça vous apprendra à se faire une
petite info intox surpris c'est une
question de ludovic barbarossa
barbarossa italien barbarossa alors
l'écart sévère alors vous êtes concentré
l'aube à evelyne amende à un club anti
dorothée à temps a été créé à la rentrée
par une association de parents d'élèves
donc on veut tous que des aces de l'info
est de l'intox lova intox intox
tu crois pas toi pourquoi elle est
charmante petite dorothée pourquoi le
sang est d'accord evelyne je suis très
ennuyé parce que dorothée sur tf1 c'est
la même famille mais la télévision est
une grande famille mais j'ai entendu
parler d'une information de ce genre et
je crains fort soit de l'information et
je le déplore d'ailleurs jal en faut
pour tous les goûts et le tulle pauvres
gens voter quelqu'un de très bien
elle avait un seul ami un seau à
champagne sur la tête de baffin
donc c'est quelqu'un de pas bien voilà
les bonnes copines non moi je crois que
c'est de l'info ouais j'aime bien
dorothée mais je peux comprendre qu'elle
peut irriter ses quatre personnes des
parents n'ont peut-être pas les enfants
donc je crois que c'est un faux bond
laurent oui c'est de l'info ou de
l'intox est en avait moi je pense que
ces lois de l'info
je sais pas vous êtes tous plantés
c'était de l'intox
sauf l'eau va hein alors ludovic
barbarossa 25 150 pont de roide
forcément fin lui gagne 500 balles et
corti tu nous donnes le score j'ai chaud
derrière mais bon je peux dire que
amanda reste à deux points et vignes de
poing et gaz lâche lova moor égalise à
deux points bravo
après l'interview première fois tu
comprendras qu'on fasse l'interview
dernier coup ça ne tenant pas ça ne
donnera pas son dernier coup de tête
[Musique]
oui c'est une maison ah bon à saint rémy
cher oui tu as vendu l'ancien et
apprennent à racheter ménages est trop
de princesse ça faisait bien c'était
avant de connaître bouygues parce que
maintenant il faut faire une coupe au
tarif
oui alors ça tu évites quoi oui qu'ils
auraient plutôt faire une petit
7e les grandes maisons bien les coups de
bluff
oh ça tout le temps quand on a signé le
contrat pour tf1 j'étais bluffé ouais tu
leur as dit que je lui proposais déjà et
de gros besoins dernier coup de boule
c'est pas un coup de boule blood bowl
alors moi j'ai agressent verbalement
lors la fête et ris parce que c'est pire
que tout passe alors je dit des
méchancetés me décourage arrivant à des
horreurs ah bon as tu vois ça j'ai une
langue
certes c'est vrai il vaudrait mieux que
je frappe les gens parce que je leur dis
des choses et pouf terrible après je
regrette
dernier coup de coeur en or dernier coup
de coeur ça tout le temps moi j'ai des
coups de coeur c'est vrai que pour des
tas de choses pour autres noms des
enfants pour des objets pour des
personnes pour tout le temps je regrette
pour ça que j'ai pas de pognon parce que
j'ai tout par des coups de coeur je
marche à l'instinct au coup de coeur des
coups de coeur pour la misère humaine
pour lui oui absolument les bosniaques
les choses comme ça peut-être les
bosniaques me touchent moins que ce que
j'ai tout près
dans dans un milieu d'amis tu vois là je
m'occupe du sida en angleterre bon en
fait donc pas du sida mais je sais que
en angleterre j'ai il ya plusieurs
associations ils sont mieux organisées
qu'en france une association dont j'ai
participé aux raids rôle qui s'occupe
d'organiser des soirées de bienfaisance
à pour le sida j'en fais partie bon jeu
le jeu le crie pas sur tous les toits je
fais en angleterre je fais pas en france
mais donc ça c'est l'échec drame de la
balle car il n'était pas du tout touché
par exemple si bien sûr mais c'est le
tueur en série je vais m'empresser de
passants balkarie plus aux petits
téléviseurs souple par le cari
presque un an après la naissance de la
communauté des états indépendants la coi
des conflits ethniques ne cessent
d'éclater un peu partout sur le
territoire de l'ex urss le sud de la
russie
véritable mosaïque de peuples tous
différents vole en éclats et plus
particulièrement dans le caucase et le
moyen-orient soviétique d'ailleurs on y
retrouve les mêmes affrontements que
dans le moyen orient pour prenant 10 il
ya des toute une série de situations qui
rappelle le liban avec des milices qui
peuvent se faire la guerre aussi
longtemps qu au liban c'est à dire
quinze ans et puis c'est le tempérament
du midi c'est le soleil c'est le
montagnard les montagnards on disait au
long poignard des sports dont naples est
comme ça chez les russes y ont
d'ailleurs fondé une une fédération des
peuples montagnards du caucase et c'est
parce que les autorités russes ont
arrêté moussa chagny bof le chef de
cette fédération des peuples montagnards
que la balle car il vient de se soulever
cette toute petite république de sept
cent mille habitants est prise dans la
tourmente nationaliste les balles car
rêve d'indépendance
[Musique]
pour la communauté russe à paris la
situation actuelle est préoccupante car
elle est tout à fait semblable à celle
qui a déclenché la guerre serbo-croate
dans l'ex yougoslavie cavaliers n'a pas
le cas et c'est une petite toupie qui
pillent ici vient lui du poker ne faut
pas duré longtemps
s'il ya des problèmes ce sont en effet
les petits gradés régime communiste
malheureusement la révolte en belle
karine et que l'une des 125 crise
ethnique recensés dans l'ex urss
parce que j'en dis un sexy boris eltsine
il avait pas de bruit ce tour de cochon
gorbatchev on n'en serait pas là vieux 1
[Musique]
s'il vous plaît c'est un lieu public
aussi noble âge
c'est un lieu public on ne fume pas bon
maintenant je suis pas l'antenne lattes
et gentil ça fait rien on ne fume pas
c'est un lieu public
messieurs en face et mon émission je
fais ce que je veux quand même je veux
pas le savoir c'est un lieu public
je suis moi ici s'il vous plaît vous
éteignez votre cigarette
merci à lui il a pourri la soirée je te
dis par action bon on va reprendre sur
des aplombs vous y êtes
laval caries
j'ai roulé alors à toi là-bas intox
tu crois pas du tout si je mens pas ça
fait un temps un peu je dirais intox
aussi bien ça balkarie non ça tu crois
pas ça fait un peu bdb dit j'ai dit un
bébé au naturel
non moi j'ai cru reconnaître didier
gustin brusquement dans le film à la fin
et ça fait un peu tout ça oui ben ali
dont je suis sûr c'est pas vrai y'a pas
de balkarie je le saurais si rim banna
qui s'était insurgé qui nous a été
envoyé par jean-luc miremont 75006 paris
qui gagne 2000 francs puisqu'on a tourné
son sujet maintenant pour savoir si la
plante et amanda c'est quand même bien
le 1
quel veinard et oui et donc s'ils
gagnent 1000 francs de plus que je
mettrais de ma poche on regarde la
réponse c'est de l'info tout à fait ben
je suis journaliste et on essaye de pas
dire trop de bêtises mais même si
c'était faux voici donc si je m'étais
trompé voici la classe universel fait
par le monde où nous avons là la balle
car il en fait une partie de la
république autonome des cas bardin et
des balles car capital naltchik avec ses
frontières dont c'est clair mais voilà
ici régulièrement l'émission donc je
crois que c'est un vrai strike vous avez
tous les trois toutes les trois toutes
les 30 et on est très très content jean
luc myre mamba lui va empocher trois
mille balles
1 ce qui n'est pas rien et corky tu va
nous donner le score écoute moi avec
toutes ses ex et molle je sais même plus
où j'en suis je sais même plus si c'est
des nems faut de l'intox et je peux vous
donner le score n'est qu'à égalité
parfaite peu partout un bonbon soir
amanda bonsoir on va commencer par des
choses un petit peu tragique
[Musique]
amanda vous rentrer de new york giants
de new york en effet et
j'ai eu beaucoup de mal à rentrer je
dois dire c'était ce n'était pas marrant
parce que j'ai je suis allé là-bas psg
une exposition de peintures à new york
et le jour même de mon vernissage
c'était justement le mardi 11 et c'était
quand il ya eu de l'attentât ce qui fait
que j'étais dans le sud de manhattan
puisque toutes les galeries de peinture
sont dans le quartier qui s'appelle
chelsea et le village c'est le village
est donc j'étais à quoi une vingtaine de
blocs des détours et comme c'était 10
heures du matin j'étais en temps
d'accrocher mais mes toiles dans la
galerie et boum badaboum tout ça est
arrivé ce qui fait que non je pense pas
qu'ils soient menées ça se pourrait mais
donc on a regardé et on a regardé tout
ça en direct et je dois dire que c'était
je resté bouche bée croyez pas ce qui
marche et ce qui arrivait et puis
ensuite donc il ya eu c'était quand les
tours se sont écroulés c'est là qu'il a
eue c'était au menu âge tu sais de fumée
de bruce hier qui envahit littéralement
toutes les rues de manhattan
alors là je suis rentré à mon hôtel
couverte de poussière et tout et je dois
dire cependant toute une semaine je suis
resté donc là bas dans mon hôtel
l'aéroport était fermé
il n'y avait pas d'avion pour rentrer
tous les jours je téléphonais en france
alors je commençais à trouver le temps
long parce que j'ai je veux rentrer chez
nous non mais je te dirais une chose
c'est que bon à part cet événement
épouvantable j'ai été frappé par la
solidarité des new yorkais du si on dit
toujours que new york est une ville
frivole ans qu'au pognon est tous là
tous les new yorkais vraiment été là ils
faisaient la queue pour donner leur sang
il
il s'est montré solidaire dans la rue
tous les soirs il allumé des bougies
il y avait des veillées et je me suis
rendu compte à quel point
en plus le maire giuliani a dit à la
télé à tous les new yorkais retourner au
boulot fait comme si rien n'était on va
pas leur montrer qu'on est à terre qu'on
est con est foutue continuer la vie
continue à new york alors c'est curieux
parce qu'au bout de deux jours donc la
ville s'est scindée en deux une partie
avait toutes belles routes quoi enfin
les trucs et l'autre partie le boulot
avait repris les gens couraient dans
broadway dans manhattan et tout ça
partout je me demande si tu ne portes
pas un peu la scoumoune non seulement
est ce qui est arrivé des choses assez
hard et tu vas à new york est la ville
et à feu sans projecteurs aussi ta tête
et bien décroché tendu on a déplacé
oui c'est vrai un mandat on peut dire
que cette tragédie survient après une
autre
[Musique]
mais nous n'en parlerons pas mandat
voilà on peut parler d'un philippe
magnac
non nous n'en parlons pas juste un mot
en passant c'est que il ya eu une odeur
dans les rues de new york il le vent a
tourné et cette odeur de crainte de
brûler de cendres a envahi les rues et
ça qui m'a le plus moi bouleversée c'est
que c'était grave dans l'odeur qui me
rappelait ma maison et ça ça m'a
beaucoup bouleversés nous n'en parlerons
pas mandat et après de me trouver là-bas
coincé on se dit pas à l'aéroport tout
le monde essayait d'embarquer sur un
avion il y avait marie christine marek
de paris première c'était très chic
parce que c'était les collections c'est
la semaine des collections a d'ailleurs
dans toutes les collections ont été
annulés moi j'ai réussi à partir sur un
avion et il ya plein de gens qui sont
restés et qui n'ont pas pu s'embarquer
non c'était s'est pas contenté de
lunettes ya pas des passagers conflit
plus fortement en revanche je te dire il
avait tellement parlé de ses incroyables
mesure de sécurité on va vous fouillez y
en a pas plus que plan vise y verra pas
à pareille franchement on n'a pas
vraiment sur la foule
moi j'étais assez oui c'est matthew
bissonnette
[Musique]
donc on va parler de l'autre tragédie
mon étoile avant tout le monde le sait
on en parle plus la page est tournée la
vie continue c'est difficile mais elle
continue d'autant plus un mandat que
vous avez l'air de vous êtes bien remise
d'une certaine façon non c'est à dire
que je je je plonge je sais je suis un
psychanalyste là j'avais toutes les
semaines chez m6 il est bien il est bien
himmich nautiz comme il te prend cher
comme tous les psychanalyse mais je vous
racontais quoi une heure souvient alors
imite notice oui je ne sais pas ce qu'il
fait quand je suis le disais je tiens la
paix et de promis le bal finalement oui
et quand je me réveille j'ai mal au cul
c'est ça que tu allais
un bon fils et un vieux couple discute
en vigueur ne passe pas par moi qu'on
dit les choses comme elles sont donc sur
les conseils de mon psy il m'a dit
sortez il faut pas rester à la maison un
plan il faut sortir dont je suis sorti
c'est vrai alors deux côtés si je sors
tous les soirs et j'essaye de m'étourdir
de ne pas penser on dire des dents elle
s'est vite consolé avance si je reste
chez moi à pleurnicher on dire on allait
en fait un peu trop là dedans de toute
façon personne négation et donc j'ai
trouvé deux charmants jeunes gens alors
il ya manuel casella mme carr italien de
26 ans
et puis elle enchaîne pas qu'est ce que
je vais si ça allait pas avec manuel
casella
alors hier j'ai la chance qu'il existe
dans notre société des très beaux jeunes
gens qui sont gérontophile et tant qu'il
y aura de la gérontophilie s'émerveiller
parce qu'ils adorent les femmes un peu
mûrement fond il y en a peut-être ici je
sais de nakheel ils prennent rien du
tout ils sont fascinés
voilà et je dois dire que c'est vrai que
ça c'est amusant de sortir avec des
jeunes gens sont très jolis donc manuel
et puis maintenant il ya ricardo perma
d'auzan
non il est pas 18 ans il ya trente ans
luis ricardo est vieux il a 30 ans
taille ricardo il marcha qu'à déambuler
en revanche ricardo vous entendez
beaucoup parlé des parce qu'il est en
train de tourner avec madonna il
commence en septembre
duffy en octobre le tournage du film de
madonna
mis en scène par son mari guy ritchie à
malte et vous entendrez beaucoup parlé
de mon petit ricardo que j'ai donc
poussé et qui doit pousser aussi méchant
alors vous me disiez vous me disiez un
mandant 96 avoir des périodes de libido
déchaînés et puis ensuite des phases de
repentir limite mysticisme pendant
lesquelles vous refusez même d'entendre
parler de sexe vous sublimer tout dans
la peinture et ce moment là et au jour
exact d'ankatso c'est qu'elle sait pas
ce nouvel pourtant un petit c'est qu'il
ya deux jours pour la première fois j'ai
repris mon pinceau
donc j'ai dans la phase must racisme
peinture vous a tant donné la phase
libye comme je n'ai pas peint depuis dix
mois c'est vrai que je me suis donc jeté
dans la libido
mais maintenant j'ai retouché je n'ai
plus besoin je te sublimer ses fils ses
optimistes ce que tu penses moment où
est ce que ce moment tout dans des tons
sais pas si tu connais en couleurs en
peinture c'est embêtant c'est qu'il n'y
a pas de jours
eva les tons sépia ce sont des tons un
peu marronnasse un petit arrêt un pc
c'est une couleur qui se perdent
et donc je peins dans cette tombe bien
alors c'est vrai vous êtes entourés de
beaucoup de mystère depuis toujours
est ce que c'est vrai par exemple que
vous êtes né à hong kong d'un père marin
il était pas marin il était officier de
maréval là rien à voir ce qu'ils me dit
j'ai été élevé dans la dans la haine des
hommes jeunes éducation religieuse très
gentil la haine enfin c'est vrai que je
voyais une éducation religieuse c'est
vrai et on me faisait voir que les
hommes disent ont abusé beaucoup les
jolies jeunes filles et bon jeu mais
finalement je me suis of me suis
toujours méfié pas aidé des messieurs
peut-être pour ça j'ai toujours choisi
d'aider êtres un peu faible un peu
vulnérable alors amende à petit on peut
le dire vous étiez assez moche
vous aviez un appareil un appareil mais
c'est pas un appareil dentaire je vais
faudrait souriez vous aviez l'a donc
tous les mois on me resserrer la paresse
c'est un cauchemar par l'habituel de fil
de fer trop grande si trop maigre trop
grande trop maigre alors ceux qui
étaient donc au départ justement moi je
trouvais des mochetés quattro grain aux
mecs trop plate et tout en fait ça s'est
révélé être un avantage parce que
justement on cherchait des filles qui
était grande et maigre et que ça pour
faire mannequin bon alors ça tombait
bien là comme françoise hardy que tu
très à la mode n'est pas là cités
c'était un petit peu le look françoise
hardy ouais c'est ça oui et alors
comment vous êtes retrouvés à londres à
la grande époque du swinging london
comment c'est arrivé ça oui j'étais dans
une agence de mannequins s'applique à
traîner relais qui avait des tas de
belle fille johanna shimkus etc et elle
m'avait emmené alain votre oui j'en vois
les couilles
oh
en place le valium le temesta l'excès
c'est que pendant des mois là j'étais
sous anti dépresseurs
finalement c'est aussi bien sans
attendre sous ricciardo je disais j'ai
tordu des onze mannequins qui m'a envoyé
à longjumeau rue catherine harley donc à
londres c'était l'époque du swinging
london à huy et la mode venait de
londres et il y avait aussi que la marie
courante etc qui avait lancé la mini
jupe et donc j'étais à londres et je
suis tombée amoureuse d'un rolling
stones voilà à brian jones global
intégré dans un com
si c'est bon d'avoir un peu vos amants
célèbres du jimi hendrix
oui non je n'ai jamais couché avec les
miens dridi la coucher chez moi à paris
hilton touché - bryan ferry c'est vrai
ça rien de série et est un garçon
charmant marié père de famille notion
david bowie oui oui oui je pense à toi
durer un an beau oui oui j'ai plus un
peu plus d'un an c'est vrai oui et vous
dit en parlant de l' os x était plus
imaginatifs que avec bryan ferry c'était
moi qui sortais avec un garçon qui se
maquillent plus que moi brian jones donc
effectivement il avait besoin d'une
maman moulin jones et l organisme
interne et je suis qui est mort dont
qu'ils avaient bu il avait besoin comme
ça qu'on s'occupe de lui
voilà et puis un jour pardon c'est tout
il n'ya pas un compagnons de la chanson
non je me suis arrêté à une certaine
époque je me suis rendu compte que je ne
voulais plus coucher avec des gens qui
faisait plus ou moins le même métier que
moi donc dorénavant ce ne sont que des
gens hors du métier des inconnus des
anonymes des plombiers des mais pippa
pas du chemin alors comme corporation
donc le goualher plombier j'en arrive au
pas parce qu'un jour amanda lear arrive
chez castel vous tombez sur dali qui
vous dit vous avez la plus belle tête de
mort que j'ai jamais vu parce que vous
aviez quoi des fossiles à maquillage
très blanc c'est ça ben c'est à dire je
venais défilé pour paco rabanne un en
bas carbone à l'époque nouba qui est
beaucoup la banane tout ça et j'étais
assez spectaculaire puisque je sortais
chez paco rabanne et d'al hima vue très
maigre très osseuse et il a dit ah quel
beau squelette alors moi on m'a déjà
rédigé un beau squelette on m'avait dit
tu as un beau cul ou des belges en mer
un squelette et j'ai pas pris ça pour un
compliment alors il a dit mais si je
vous assure vous avez la plus belle tête
de mort que jamais et dont le sudiste
mais qui les singles et en plus c'est
une offense je veux plus jamais le voir
ça a été une très mauvaise impression de
départ mais c'est comme dans les films
américains
ça commence toujours par dice a sûrement
alors là
après ça a été j'ai été séduite après
voilà vous vous débarquez à l'hôtel
meurice avec une fouille absolument
incroyable alors vous dites les gars
vous il est l'ambassadeur d'espagne
avait quelques roachs il quitte la
mairie puis à bien des fausses vierge
solidifie vrai on en trouvait plus rêvé
de tout des coiffeurs des dieux coucher
avec lui oui d'un lit pendant 15 16 ans
c'est vrai que ça a été une relation
très très très intenses parce que
c'était à la fois mon petit ami mon père
mon amant mon professeur de dar c'est
juste qu'elle a été une fille excusez
moi mais je le dis souvent c'est dans
cette émission et je le répète encore ce
soir
gala 10 est formidable elle disait si
mon mari est heureux avec amanda je suis
heureuse
j'aimerais que beaucoup de femmes
prennent exemple non je sais je sais je
sais ces gars-là est exceptionnel parce
que moi même extrêmement jalouse je
n'envisage absolument pas de de dire à
mon fiancé mon mari mon ami oui oui tu
veux te l'a tapée bon c'est pas cher que
le gala comme avec dix ans de plus que
dali est très très très portée sur la
chose à cette époque non plus
oui elle m'a franchement si elle m'a dit
que je suis tellement soulagé que vous
soyez là comme ça vous allez avec lui à
toutes les soirées les machins lâcher ça
je suis tranquille je vais au théâtre
tranquillement j'ai bien mériter ça elle
écrivait son journal et vous faisait le
boulot voilà quoi mais vous en faites
vous dit si ça vous arrive et vous
diriez qui sait cette [ __ ] décolorés
qui vient me piquer mon jules tout à
fait alors autre mystère
évidemment vous le connaissez vous le
savez parce que ma fille faisait souvent
parler vous avez même déjà pu
effectivement pas fille y a pas que ben
africaine a parlé c'est de jouer quand
même que ce soit en réserve le problème
il ya quelques mois j'ai regardé une des
émissions et tu recevais rocco siffredi
rocco siffredi et alors ça m'a beaucoup
verrez pas ce que tu disais un rocco y
at il une femme
avec qui tu aimerais coucher et il à
dire mandali c'est vrai parce que
j'aimerais justement enfin découvrir ce
fameux mystère et c est bon ensuite j'ai
revu rocco siffredi est alors le sort
n'a pas de problème le seul il est
charmant il est donc libre
c'est qu'il doit percer à jour ce n'est
pas d'hier
même tu vois un super macho comme lui un
super état l'on est fasciné bien sûr
tout ce qui tourne autour du mystère de
l'ambiguïté l'un sur pourquoi parce que
justement les filles d'aujourd'hui bon
les arts 2 par exemple docteur n'avait
dans ta dernière émission était dans un
jour n'ont plus aucun mystère quand
elles se font pas désiré et ça c'est ce
qui manque
bond est qu'amanda lear est arrivé pour
lancer ses premiers disques avec auréolé
du nouveau mystère est ce que c'est un
homme est ce que c'est une femme on ne
sait pas d'où vient-elle quel âge as tu
es toutes ces conneries la sacrée autour
de moi une aura de mystère qui fascinait
les gens la minute où ils m'ont vu toute
nue dans playboy photographié sur un lit
ils ont intimé il était extrêmement déçu
lundi mais c'est ray dvd entre amanda
c'était un coup marketing en fait
c'était un coup marketing de très
mauvais goût mais qui a vachement bien
fonctionné puisque vingt ans après tu en
parlant quand on en parlera puisque
mortes qu'on en parle j'en pense qu on
ne se rappellera pas de mes chances bien
sûr enfin peut-être même pas de mes
tableaux mais on se rappellera amanda
lear qui s'était déjà celle là ab oui
celle dont on disait bien sûr elle
pasqua ont touché au plus profond de
l'hydrosphère de jacques dau ne vous
fait pas
[Applaudissements]
non la vente à genève en parler
maintenant les gens ils font les 26 noms
mais tout le monde se demande au fond de
moi suis-je [ __ ] suis-je une lesbienne en
quoi cela fort de mr reste entière moi
personnellement mais pas pour moi et
pour moi en tous les cas
non ce qui est extraordinaire laurence
il ya des spécialistes italiens qu'on
fait des agrandissements besson
si l'amendé à lire nullement parce que
les poils pubiens des heures des femmes
sont pas plantés dans le même sens il y
avait des photos dans playboy bon très
explicite belles photos d'ailleurs et il
avait mis avec des loupes il avait
agrandi les poils pubiens on dit bien
quelles sont ces puces et voilà je ne
savais pas ça mais paraît que ceux des
garçons j'aimerais pousse pas dans le
sens critique des couettes ont trouvé
quoi hommes
ils ont trouvé que c'était poil et non
le plus simple le plus sain comme un
mandat pour faire taire la rumeur serait
quand même été joueur les habits de
faire comme celle de faire un enfant
non faut déjà trouver la mer
moi je suis contre j'ai touché des
hadiths récentes faisant je suis trop
vieille maintenant mais même et en plus
j'ai toujours dit que dans le showbiz on
ne devait pas se reproduire
1 les vedettes sont des monstres faut
pas qu'ils se reproduisent
tu te vois toi ayant une maman qui met
des fossiles qui va à la télé au lieu
d'amener à l'école tous les matins tu
dis m'attend c'est pas une maman ce
happy excuse moi mon chéri maintenant je
pars en tournée pendant six mois où tu
as une vraie maman ou alors c'est pas
une maman saisi qu'une vedette de cinéma
alors pour savoir la vérité il faudra
attendre l'autopsié
sauf si vous fait incinérer
oui peut-être c'est pas ou alors si je
ne meurs pas oui comme dali je ne fait
rien comme tout le monde
alors j'ai été animatrice télé c'était
un peu touché tellement triste et les
chanteuses actrices de cinéma
et là vous sortez un single qui est
magnifique c'est comment on fait ça
s'appelle love boat on écoute souvent
dans cette émission un mandat vient de
faire une reprise
génial
[Musique]
[Musique]
ok
wu
m
de là
mais
eh ouais
[Musique]
tout le monde la connaît c'est elle a
croisé bien sûr on le pense souvent
riches ce n'est qu'un single de l'album
qui sort le 30 octobre voilà alors un
mandat un mandat on a beaucoup parlé on
va faire une interview
oui non et vous ne répondrez amanda lear
que par oui ou par non
bush
en rouge
rigal
vous avez bougé par le gia lâm en argent
pur à lui mais je suis désolé ok on
allume heures désolé on va faire une
interview
oui non en bouche le génial
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien amanda lear si vous trompiez votre
jules est ce que vous lui diriez non est
ce que vous croyez en dieu
oui est-ce que vous donnez dans la rue à
ceux qui font la manche
oui parce qu'il ya des trucs que vous
refusez de fer au lit oui quoi je me
suis plié et moi même je suis auto
piégée olala j'aimerais le savoir il ya
des trucs dégoûtant brawn on a mûri un
dessin manga et c'est vrai c'est ce
qu'on dit à chaque fois mais on
s'embrasse sur la bouche avec la langue
de trucs comme ça avec ram
il ya des trucs et un monde plein de
gens aiment faire et moi par
particulièrement quoi un exemple la
vaisselle c'est très coûteux a des poils
plein les dents avez vous réalisez vos
rêves d'enfants non quand même ça fait
le plus gros party on a république far
tu aspire à devenir enfin quand je dis
tu es sûr que tu voudrais être président
un jour non
amanda est ce que vous avez déjà eu des
expériences diensten sexe vous
rencontrez quelqu'un vous rencontrez
quelqu'un à brit-brit une demi-heure
après c'est dans les chiottes du
restaurant windham hier d'accord bras
quand tu arrives tu es un raptus dans
l'ascenseur ça vous est arrivé déjà la
métare aimeriez-vous devenir amanda lear
la maîtresse d'un chef d'état oui avis
aux amateurs imagine le pouvoir que tu
as c'est toi qui dirige parce qu'il fait
tout ce que tu lui un mandat avez vous
déjà connu la dépendance sexuelle
oui non mais c'est quelque chose de
terrible
rogge ce week en dit ce mec gelé dans la
peau radecki me touche ça pose à sa
bouche et tous et c'est dramatique je
vous écrivais souffre terriblement
est ce que vous croyez à mende à dire
qu'il ya quelque chose après la mort oui
des composés si vous avez déjà fait
l'amour à 5 à 5
non c'est beaucoup c'est un gage en
faire des soustractions attend à 5 des
voisines la taille du lit à quatre noms
à trois temps aa oui ah oui oui 4 oui
oui oui oui il y avait des femmes non
des animaux
at the amanda lear avez vous plus de
qualités que de défauts non oui y at il
un fantasme que vous n'avez pas réalisé
oui ma fille en même temps en même temps
sinon c'est vrai il faut qu'il faut de
toute façon qui est toujours un fantasme
non réalisés parce que tu attends quand
on a réalisé tous ses fantasmes d'abord
on a plus que des bons souvenirs ses
invités fantasmes et puis la vie est
triste faut toujours espérer encore de
faire quelque chose amanda lear est ce
que vous vous aimez non d'accord ça va
venir ça va venir je travaille là dessus
avec mon psy juste c'est pas jérémy
verbe c'est donc moi sur l a dit qu'il
prenait son enfant est ce que vous
feriez un film porno pour un million de
francs non 2 millions non non mais je
lui aurais posé la question il ya 15 ans
j'aurais dit oui parce que je trouve que
j'étais encore photographia le leur
maintenant ça vieillit jolie quand même
à partir d'un certain âge je trouve
quand même des zones actuellement faut
se fier millions de francs novembre
200 millions je pourrais pas payer
arrête
non j'ai pas de la rue aux livres alors
messieurs votre chanson préférée
amanda lear
[Musique]
ça va mon cas je vais expliquer à nos
amis téléspectateurs pourquoi vous êtes
là d'abord parce qu'on vous aime
beaucoup et puis ensuite parce que dans
le deuxième tome donc de de gaulle mon
père
l'amiral parle de de gaulle et les
femmes donc quand on s'est vus pour
préparer cette émission je lui ai dit
amiral quelle femme souhaitez vous avoir
sur le plateau ce soir là et il m'a dit
amanda lear pas si gentil voilà oui ou
amanda lear mais pas vous j'avais
beaucoup d'esprit je vous j'ai entendu
avec philippe bouvard à brossolette des
enseignants mais pas seulement
il ya longtemps que je sais très gentil
merci c'était ma tante et je veux j'ai
remarqué que vous aviez de l'esprit et
du talent mais voilà dans les entretiens
télévisés entre haute et voilà mais
aussi que vous avez une carrière de
chanteuse c'est vrai c'est pas ben ben
trop de ses supérieurs
[Musique]
voilà mandat donc ce qu'on peut dire
quand même c'est que tu es aujourd'hui
la femme que le fils du général de
gaulle souhaite voir auprès de lui sur
un plateau de télévision elle-même sa
soeur elodie
yahoo
non
[Musique]
déclaré je ne sais pas si on se
souviendra de mes chansons plus tard
mais je suis sûr qu'on se rappellera
d'une chose on ne savait pas si j'étais
un homme ou une femme et vous avez
beaucoup joué sur cette ambiguïté
amira responsable c est ce que c'est on
sait que tu es un garçon est ce que si
j'attends est ce que c'est cette
ambiguïté est ce que vous savez bien
c'est les rumeurs qui ont couru sur
amanda lear est ce que c'est cette
ambiguïté filles et garçons qui vous
séduit amiral normes y avoir d'ambiguïté
chez le talent dont je m'occupe c'est
que je sais havre est perçue non parce
que
ce qui peut dire quand même amiral vous
n'êtes pas le premier vous le sachiez
parce que amanda a quand même déjà
séduit salade ordalie qui adorent et
amanda lear david bowie manuel casella
ricardo perdre 100 mais où avec avec les
choeurs d'opéra mandat non non il n'est
plus dans le paysage en californie
non non non je ne sais pas dit que
j'étais libre mais enfin le dernier qui
viennent si tu es là ricardo on merci
beaucoup merci merci non rien gg j'ai
une vie amoureuse oui comme tout le
monde et puis elle n'est pas faite pour
vous ennuyer avec ça ici alors un mandat
pour accentuer votre voix grave et votre
côté androgyne qui ont séduit
effectivement beaucoup de gens la vue
vous avant les enregistrements de vos
disques vous fumiez des cigarettes et
vous buviez du whisky et alors ce que
j'ai appris en lisant le livre de
l'amiral de gaulle c'est que son père
s'il n'aimait pas savoir c'est à dire
qu'il voulait changer sa voix le général
ils prenaient dépasser 2 ça va il brasse
et oui lui trouvais qu'ils la voient
trop roque trop éraillée oui quand on
mar 11 h
il l'aurait voulu il aurait voulu avoir
une voix de basse voilà c'est vrai il a
il n'aimait pas tellement ça voyez par
exemple quand il a dit les fasse quand
il a dit à libération paris outragé
paris brisé paris martyrisé
il n'est pas content il n'y a pas du
tout contents de cette déclaration
ici jean moulin était tropez murat
ne l'a pas trouvée bonne image ne
convenait pas c'était à côté
dans la famille alors maintenant je vais
te dire un mandat j'ai cherché les
points comme l'amiral
j'ai cherché des points communs entre
toi mandat elle général de gaulle
enregistraient ce qui alarme et je suis
grande comme j'ai trouvé cette histoire
de voix je suis vachement content parce
que je me suis dit amanda qui fument des
cigarettes qui boit du whisky pour pour
changer sa voile général de gaulle qui
trouve sa voix trop haut perchée donc là
j'avais vraiment trouver quelque chose
qui ont séduit la voix les hommes
politiques savent très bien que la voie
est très importante et donc il séduit
seller un secours qui séduit donc ce
sont des grands séducteurs les hommes
politiques je vois aujourd'hui peut-être
pas les budgets des rôles de gaulle mais
maintenant tu regardes berlusconi tout
ça et c'est ce sont des acteurs presque
ils savent qu'on leur écrit des textes
ils les répètent devant la glace
un geste et tout et c'est très important
et les les gens comme moi qui fonda
télévision du spectacle c'est la même
chose on sait très bien que la voie est
très très important moi ma voix je peux
la mode et je peux la faire plus basses
plus hot fuzz attend la bande avait une
voie pour rigoler comme ça fait lui une
voie de mecs comme ça va ah non mais pas
que ça vient at il dit à fourmies
rigoler fait d'une boîte fille
bombardier
mais contient peut pas la mairesse
micheline dax quoi oui alors aidants
quand on écoute carmen un des charmes de
cette opérette c'est que la voix très
basse à laquelle peut défendre la
cantatrice et carmen elle même mais
c'étaient les opéras de loin ah oui quel
opérette vous préférez de tout rond je
ne peux pas dire les mêmes que celles
qu'ont les opérettes d'offenbach
ah oui la belle hélène la belle hélène
je me souviens plus de la mélodie étonné
cette voie
et bien c'est le choeur antique qui est
derrière et effet les réflexions ce qui
est très intéressant dans la belle
hélène le peuple fait des réflexions sur
les vedettes qui s'avance sur l'avant de
la salle c'était quoi l'air et l'air
s'était alors trois barbus qui s'avance
but qui s'avance but que s'avance et
agamemnon leroy un barbu qui s'avance un
peu plus précis ça alors
question voix je le connais comme des
porcs les gens l'ont vu question
question voix j'ai trouvé des points
communs entre toi et le général de
gaulle malheur question amour pas du
tout le général de gaulle était vraiment
sur le sujet vraiment de l'amour disons
des femmes et des quand même très
sérieux parce qu'on lui connaît
finalement très peu d' aventure en
dehors de contrats mois on les connaît
très peu d' aventure en dehors de tante
yvonne de votre maman
il est gentil mais il y avait une jeune
femme à la ville ou de au début de la
guerre de 14 mai qui est décédé à ce
moment-là il là ils l'avaient une
cousine éloignée qui avait attiré son
attention
thérèse elle est mort pendant la guerre
voilà puis c'est tout et c'est tout ben
moi j'ai un flirt avec gilles mais je
sais pas si c'est vrai joli filet pour
la fidélité jeunes vers l'extase toi
aussi l'abstinence caméras système juste
pour la fidélité à van baker tous ces
bons amis drague tout ce qui bouge
un bon ça bouge plus on est bas
alors tu lui dis je vous ai dit que
s'ils voulaient retrouver
arielle dombasle c'est lundi soir sur
france 2 et si vous les retrouver amanda
lear donc c'est sûr match tv2 s'appelle
tendance et rencontre lundi soir
voilà et on vous retrouve aussi dans
l'émission de stéphane bern
oui sur canal l'ex et 20 de ceux
attendus cette semaine et puis j'ai un
film qui sort là qui s'appelle archives
de nuit et puis et puis je travaille à
un livre mais tout ça on en parlera
après un quart face au non alors amanda
vous restez avec nous oui parce que j'ai
une folie d'interview à vous faire là
mais on va libérer parce que franchement
la libérer deux bouts
non
j'espère que l'amiral de gaulle
reviendra pour le troisième tome est
donc le kart un arrêt tchad et une carte
de client mais il va revenir je l'adoré
il est beaucoup plus décontractée que la
première fois avec elle déconnait très
en forme très en forme finit bien alors
en fait je voulais que que philippe
sorte parce qu'on va faire une interview
où là dedans au dehors un non non non
l'interview test
[Musique]
alors allons guérir on va faire une
interview thèse pour en finir une fois
pour toutes avec cette histoire
est ce une fille et un garçon moi
personnellement j'en peux plus je n'en
peux plus mais on jamais vu ça quand
j'entends parler de ça et là bas on va
savoir la vérité pas retrouvé le mondial
par la pluie
non je n'ai pas retrouvé leur calme
alors c'est comment on va savoir la
vérité
bon à savoir la vérité parce qu'on va
poser des questions très fine qui vont
tout de suite nous permettre de savoir
si amanda lear est une fille ou un
garçon
il est fort ce thierry est ce que vous
savez faire un créneau oui bien sûr pas
tous les cas nous on connaît la réponse
alors est ce que est ce que un mandat
vous comprenez les règle du hors-jeu au
foot
non là ça le foot ah non ça je suis
désolé
la troisième mi-temps à la rigueur mais
le enjeu non ça veut dire ça c'est
acquiesça avec le gardien c'est pour toi
c'est cadeau est ce que vous pensez
qu'en amour les préliminaires sont
importants oui les préliminaires sont
importants et je dirais même plus
souvent il ya que les préliminaires qui
sont bien
elle adore se faire prier
elle s'est ralliée en tout cas les gens
peuvent voter chez eux
l'appellation de taxe est bien sûr mais
c'est intéressant
est-ce que tu bois une bière après
l'amour que vous endormez tout de suite
après avoir fait l'amour non après
finalement je vais appelle un taxi la
plupart à benghazi
quand avez vous eu envie de vous gratter
les couilles pour la dernière fois
d'ailleurs ça c'est une chose que je ne
comprends pas pourquoi vous vous grattez
vous les couilles vous avez des poufs
mais c'est un confort de témoin les
forces à la trouille je ne comprends pas
le bon bout enfin je sais pas nous on ne
craque pas alors on n'a pas si on est
propre besoin de se gratter la dernière
fois un peu moins non je veux bien
gratter celle toi monsieur s'il me le
demande très gentiment mais avec les
ongles que j'ai merci un mandat
[Musique]
amanda lear
c'est essentiel à tous était en
compagnie de l'amiral philippe de gaulle
et admirateurs d'amanda lear à qui
j'avais demandé quelle femme il
souhaitait avoir avec lui ce soir et on
refaire l'amiral me dit-on dans
l'au-delà dit je veux amanda lear vous
êtes revu depuis
non non c'est fini on en est resté là
mais je plais beaucoup aux hommes
politiques un texto rien il parle
souvent de vous vous savez ça s'est il
paraît d'après michel tauriac il est
resté très très imprégné de cette
rencontre c'est bien longtemps sans
renier mes premiers mots juste au dessus
vous plaisait beaucoup vieux vous un non
merci beaucoup
non c'est pas parce que là on va parler
on va parler de salvador dali ça fait
quand même publié chez michel lafon vous
aussi un livre qui s'appelle monde ali à
l'occasion du centenaire de la naissance
de salvador dali en 1904 voilà alors au
delà de la caricature généralement
véhiculée par les médias
c'est à dire je suis fou du chocolat
lanvin l'anagramme de son nom a vida
dollars voilà vous essayer de montrer un
délit un peu plus sereine
j'aime pas le mot réhabiliter mais c'est
vrai que dali souffre d'une très
mauvaise image on se rappelle de lui en
effet la caricature le type qui voulait
choquer le provocateur les moustaches
rigolote etc
on oublie un petit peu que c'était quand
même un peintre fantastique dessinateur
incroyable et puis surtout un génie et
alors c'est sa faute de toute façon
comme tous les gens qui aiment provoquer
gainsbourg pareil quand ils voulaient
les billets ils savent très bien qu'en
provoquant ils vont se faire taper
dessus rond mais c'est plus fort qu'eux
il peut pas s'en empêcher
pareilles ma fille prend la provocation
ça va il peut et sait pas où on peut
s'arrêter et donc daly était comme ça et
je le déplore parce que je moi j'ai
connu un dali l'être humain ses
faiblesses sa gentillesse son humour et
eau et non pas l'homme public l'homme
publiquement m était franchement
antipathique vrai que dali l'homme
public c'est pas c'est tout ce que j'ai
testé ce mec avec une limousine un
chauffeur qui dépensait des fortunes de
l'époque du lait sont pas oubliés je
demande à acheter de gauche à l'époque
et
ça me choquer beaucoup c'était pensée
mai 68 et tout ça tu arrêtes de te
poudre et la foufoune oui et je mets
donc en rencontrant dali et qu'on se
batte d'asile que mois après je vais
mettre ça sur le nez plein de boutons
mois la semaine prochaine avec ces
[ __ ] alors amanda votre livre parle
de dali mais au delà de dali vous
raconter deux époques absolument
fabuleuse d'abord c'est le le swinging
london
les années soixante à londres avec les
beatles les stones brian ferry david
bowie et les années soixante dix à new
york avec warhol paloma picasso diane de
furstemberg donc c'est un livre qui à la
fois raconte un grand peintre et en même
temps trace le portrait d'une époque
c'est oui parce que l'un d'eux mars le
président ce n'est pas ma biographie
c'est vrai de dali mais comme dali
connaissait le monde entier c'est vrai
qu'à travers lui j'ai rencontré j'ai
côtoyé des gens jamais je n'aurais
espéré mains croisées dans la rue au
livre comment 165 quand vous rencontrez
salvador dali vous êtes tous les deux en
train de pisser chez castel je crois
qu'on est d'accord
excuse moi mais c'est vrai que j'ai
dallier il était très pipi caca c'est
vrai on le coût pour mon peuple non j'ai
écopé ce moment-là tout il était très
près on voit qu'on se rencontre et
d'arrêter que ces histoires amanda est
anna mais tous maintenant on sait que
vous êtes une femme également s'en fout
que j'avais ça montre est nouveau ça
pour quoi
on va faire une échographie là tout de
suite non une échographie ou les qu'on
passe en direct mais volontiers mais
vous avez un médecin ici qui peut qui
peut est-ce que vous êtes prêts à vous
faire examiner en permamence à la
télévision
coloscopie je suis sûr alla alors pour
vous rencontrer d'avis quand vous
rencontrez dali donc vous êtes avec
votre fiancée de l'époque et irlandais
ce qui s'appelle tara d en compagnie de
brian jones et donc vous rencontrez
saveurs dalli à l'époque il se fait
appeler le divin le divin d'allier jour
il aimait bien ça ils donnent des
surnoms à tout le monde souffre à vous
parce qu'il vous a rappelé sur toi ça
veut dire qu'il ne retenait pas le nom
des gens c'était impossible pour lui
c'est toujours approximative c'est par
roselyne bachelot juridique h à lauryn
hill à la sonorité comme ça il a
rencontré sylvie vartan et un câble se
rappeler si leur temps ils appeler
cécile bertrand 1 que la sonorité
c'était un petit peu ça et donc été
préféré donner des surnoms comme l'ont
rappelé thierry paraire disent on ne
pouvait pas se rappeler ardisson à
lalonde qu il aurait dit non il aurait
dû pour l'histoire
ils sont où calissons voilà auquel ils
ont tous un truc comme ça que si leur
donner des surnoms dont elle est très
jolie chinoise il l'appelait le gars de
rouge
il s'appelait louis xiv y avait une dame
blonde avec des cheveux très bouclés et
très imposant plein de bijoux il disait
c'est le roi louis xiv il appelé louis
xiv à htc
donc il parlait tout le monde comme ça
au masculin et je dois dire que
s'apprêtaient beaucoup à confusion déjà
à l'école alors au début vous le trouvez
quand même très chaud villa un peu gras
vous trouvez un peu ridicule au départ
non un peu prétentieux tout pensé qu'à
l'époque le jeu j'étais très attiré par
les chanteurs rock et guitariste et ça
donc c'était mon truc c'était plutôt les
limites avec des cheveux longs et tout
et je vois ce monsieur qui était plutôt
antipathique et des messages envoyés à
un kilomètre qui se maquillent et en
plus avec du crayon noir et tout quand
il m'a embrassé poste et sa mousse à
gérer
et donc je c'est vrai qu'il m'a pas paru
trop sympa et en plus de ça c'était pas
mon préféré parce que je faisais les
beaux-arts et j'adorais picasso et pas
du tout la peinture de dali alors
évidemment tout le monde se demandait ce
que vous êtes taper dali et il ya des
révélations dans votre bouquin il était
en fait fasciné par les par les
prouesses sexuelles de sa cour mais lui
d'après ce qu'on comprend c'est qu'il
était impuissant fait des voyeurs quoi
les regarder c'est à dire qu'il était
tout un chercher défi pour poser pour
lui
or quand nous on a une très jolie fille
et qu'on le dit vous voulez vous
déshabiller mademoiselle entièrement nue
pour la rassurer évidemment la fille se
dit va me sauter dessus c'est un vieux
cochon dont paul rassurer et rassurer je
suis impuissant de son jeu et alors il a
rassuré les filles dont qui disait tout
le temps je suis impuissant mais enfin
les gens qui le disent tout le temps tu
veux
c'est quand même bizarre et on s'est
aperçu petit à petit qu'on fait n'était
pas vraiment impuissant il aimait bien
se donner cette image et il était
surtout très cérébral comme beaucoup
d'artistes où son génie c'est s était
pas l'acte physique tripoter quelqu'un
qui l'intéressait c'était tout ça parce
que france en profite pour robots palper
un petit peu ma fille a longtemps non
vraiment c'est mon seul intérêt ce que
les témoins a pas du tout or ces autres
par la place alors votre première
rencontre il vous demande si vous êtes
lesbiennes oui ça réussit ça
l'intéressait beaucoup comme un peu
voyeur il aimait bien savoir que les
filles des lesbiennes très les mecs pays
d'aix et alors manger tout ça ça
m'intéresse pas mais tout cela c'est
lutter pas homo il avait essayé et il a
bien décrit alors qu'à la fin c'est
garcia lorca qui avait essayé parce que
c'est alors qu'a été amoureux de lui et
d'alliés avait pas dit non d'ailleurs
mais ça lui adresser mal de gens
cette sodomie avait été arrêté à mi
parcours est là parce qu'au début paris
ça fait très mal shepard la première
fois amanda alzheimer
vingt ans
voilà mettez fétichiste ils adorent et
vos pieds par les sas entre demi bunuel
toute cette période la plus réaliste
les bottines lacées tous ces trucs à
savoir plus enfin en recul et un pied
c'est pas évident il aurait bien aimé
les robins des bois parce qu'il aimait
beaucoup tout ce qui était un humour un
petit peu déçue mais je suis sûr qu'ils
auraient mais il aimait beaucoup rire il
a de la mairie gaulle ex et il aimait
beaucoup qu'elle devait s'appeler gérard
seti
j'adore les majors seti avec une série à
chaud c'est se transformer en far qui se
souvient des gérard sétif
il a joué dans bangkok a tu t'en
souviens c'est bravo serre et donc alors
oui il ya une histoire extraordinaire
donc c'est que davie était marié avec
gala la fameuse e gala nom des gens la
première rencontre ils vous vend à elle
comme un aspirateur et via les
formidables achever les mains il est
très maladroit et c'était très important
pour lui que galam accepte parce qu'il
est temps c'était la femme légitime il
allait pas le dire j'ai rencontré une
fille super je voudrais qu'elle vient de
vivre à la maison
bon c'était mal barré donc il m'a dit
faut que vous fassiez bonne impression
alors moi j'ai fait un effort je me suis
maquillée bien tout ça et quand josé
présenté à gallas était le pire bilan
parce que il n'arrêtait pas de dire
regardez regarde ma petite chérie regard
comme elle est belle
tournez-vous on a tourné au fait de voir
vos jambes sera égale elle tire une
tronche pas plus d'alice comme un
aspirateur mais je vous assure elle est
vraiment très bien puis elle est très
intelligente tu verras plus elle parle
plusieurs langues et gala de plus en
plus âgés mais qu'est ce que c'est que
cette gonzesse et tout ça non c'était
c'était pas bien d'une heure vous mangez
beaucoup lors de ce premier dîner mois
chez
dit qu'elle a dit qu'est ce qu'elle
mangeait alors c'est la politesse
hélas cette phrase terrible elle dit si
vous étiez poli vous viendriez pas chez
moi avec une mini jupe qui montre tout
quoi vraiment mais c'est elle à l'époque
de marie courante et minijupe moi
j'avais voyagé projet pilote aura de la
foule et est envoyé et égale à tous
annoncé s'est pas fait bonne impression
la seule première fois sap a été
terrible puisque très sympathique de la
part de gala c'est que finalement elle
part en voyage et elle vous donne à davy
galand me disais mais moi j'ai mon mari
elle était folle de son mari et mon mari
est heureux avec un mandat voilà je suis
heureux ce moment voilà quand henry ces
normes sont énormes et vous raconter
dali peintre qui détestait les femmes
qui faisait de la peinture parce qu'il
disait que le génie est dans les
couilles et comme moi quand j'ai annoncé
sur la chaîne ont le talent justement
chez les messieurs réside là dedans et
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs ils disaient
qu'ils sont impuissants ils ne font pas
des enfants on peut pas faire des
enfants quand on est michel-ange ou
léonard de vinci
donc tout ça est sublimé et ça te sort
partons pinceaux comment est ce que je
voulais éviter un rappel textile
révélations dans votre bouquin c'est
qu'en fait cela dit il avait un [ __ ]
qui recopier les photos il est parti à
lille
des tableaux qui s'appelait c'est dans
ce tableau il ya des partis un peu
chiante à faire le fond le ciel comme ça
donc bea était un brave petit artisan
qui faisait ça très bien et puis
d'aliapur est arrivé alors et mettez les
touches génial et que tu m'aimais j'ai
beaucoup appris j'ai beaucoup mais on le
regarde en peintre moi qui est sûr ce
bea qui était son amant fêtes étaient
logés comme un chien empaillé mais tu
adores abyss plaignez pas ali traiter
tout le monde très malsain c'est vrai il
faut le dire il n'était pas très gentil
avec ses collaborateurs alors vous
raconter le personnage dans la vie
quotidienne par exemple nettoyer jamais
ses lunettes
elle était très sale et comme il était
très coq et souvent ils voulaient pas
mettre ses lunettes
on y voyait pas grand chose du sauna
géré par exemple dans les taxis pour pas
mettre ses lunettes quand il avait un an
à new york au compteur il sortait des
billets de 100 dollars et y donner aux
chauffeurs ayant le chauffeur 100
dollars 200 dollars 302 y avait créé
trois dollars 56 eu plus de 350 $ et le
chauffeur d et thank you mr gaal et god
bless alors moi j'ai tout cafter à gala
elle a arrêté de lui donner de l'argent
mais aussi des tricots de corse
alkylants privé 20 sur lesquels matin il
aimait beaucoup prendre son petit
déjeuner en tricot de corps est alors il
faisait tomber y tremper son croissant
dans du miel est alors le miel
dégouliner un petit peu sur son truc
et puis avait des taches de café au lait
il aurait été un autre par dessus de
cinar était impropre mais gardez le sale
toujours en dessous parce qu il est
juste regarder
il était fasciné par les excréments de
rats par la pourriture
par exemple un soir ils ont dîné chez
chez un ami de dali 1 et qui s'appelle
plat il y avait des traces d'explosifs
sur la culotte et alors c'est la soirée
ambitionne va voir d'abord ce qu'elles
sont les cieux vraiment le 13 demeure
sur les chiens il était très pipi caca
un été arrêté il est tombé en extase
devant une énorme crottes en plus était
une perte de 2 nous savaient et ils me
disaient mais regardez comme c'est bon
ou y regarder alors moi je disais bon
ben ça va on continue le nom mais non
mais regardez alors il regardait les
ailes des mouches la couleurs irisées ça
a été assez répugnant
mais vie d'un produit pour penser que je
pense que paf a du talent parce que moi
maintenant je dois révélé une chose
c'est que quand on a écrit sa première
pièce robin des bois d'à peu près
alexandre dumas on écrivait chez moi
dans ma cuisine et un jour peuvent
façonner et comme mois de janvier oui
c'est important ça va mais comme il
n'avait pas eu le temps de m'acheter des
fleurs il m'avait amené une crotte
j'allais dans un mignon mais j'ai trouvé
ça incroyable de pouvoir prendre une
crotte congelés quoi ça incroyable à une
crotte combien ça va mieux le psy qu'est
ce qu'il en est
il est confiant en fait vous étiez très
amoureuse de dali simplement c'est vrai
que vous avez connu 40 ans trop tard
quoi c'est ça c'est ça oui j'avais connu
oui c'est vrai je leur ai posé sur ie
marié serait peut-être temps parce que
il était fascinant il était cultivé il
savait tout ils avaient des anecdotes
invraisemblable me raconter je sais pas
ses rencontres avec klitschko qui avec
walt disney avec marilyn monroe il avait
connu une montée dont moi j'étais
fasciné là maintenant je parle beaucoup
mais à l'époque je disais rien voir à
écouter et s'étaient battus
un type comme ça on l'est plus il était
aussi très possessif parce que quand
vous êtes avec david bowie par exemple
ils vous ont les madahib auj il aimait
pas de vidéo ripressione scooper bas il
m'a dit qu'ils nous foutent avec ce mec
qui se maquillent plus que vous et
non il est pas beau il enfin salissent
couper les liens le côté gore le côté
vous raconter tout ça vous raconter
aussi cette déchéance et dernière fois
que que vous le voyez 1983 et refuse
toute la lumière
il veut vous voir dans le noir on s'est
rencontrés dans le noir total ils
voulaient plus que je le vois alors très
bien qu'il était on a vu les photos elle
lui donne un tuyau dans le nez tout ça
il y avait un certain exhibitionnisme
même à se faire voir ses doutes en
spectacle le même mourant est malade et
tout mais visiblement ils avaient ils
avaient honte que je le vois comme ça il
dit je veux vous rappeler toujours de
moi très beau penser que je vais me
rappeler un très beau très fringant et
dori dans le noir complet et c'était
assez émouvant et puis après ça il a
fini bien tristement comme tous ces gens
qui n'ont pas d'enfant il est mort tout
seul entouré de gens qui voulaient faire
du pognon
dalli a disparu aujourd'hui si vous
étiez la muse d'un peintre voudriez être
la muse de quel peintre
je ne sais pas si aujourd'hui il y en a
qui me fascine autant parce que si c'est
les boules un téléphone et chats
préfèrent l'interview déjà dit déjà ni
avant nous a déjà dit déjà dit désolé
c'était ma dernière paire en 48
on me l'a jamais dit on me dit souvent
saison c'était ma dernière paire en 41 3
1 les déclarants terre est-ce qu'on vous
ai déjà dit toi ma chérie tu as les yeux
qui crie braguette
non mais c'est une bonne expérience
pourrait vous le dire parce que c'est
tout à fait ça est-ce que vous avez déjà
dit ça vous dérange pas que ma femme
regarde oui mais ça ça me plaît pas du
tout ce qu'on vous a déjà dit ça vous
dérange pas que ma mère regarde non non
dits plutôt surtout le dit pas ma maman
fin est ce que vous a déjà dit ça vous
dérange pas si je demande à mes potes de
nous rejoindre
oui ça met de plus en plus on dit ça
parce que ça s'est passé c'est nouveau
cette histoire de d'échangisme tous les
copains ensemble alors mois qui suivent
tous pas partageuse c'est pas mon truc
ça mais c'est vrai que c'est de plus en
plus est ce qu'on vous a déjà dit merci
pour cette nuit mais désolé il faut que
j'y aille j'ai un conseil des ministres
oui dans leur égard oui trop tard non
pas un conseil des ministres ont dit des
fois j'ai un concert où g
1 j'ai une interne stade de france est
ce qu'on vous a déjà dit c'est quoi ces
prix exorbitants des tarifs non non est
ce qu'on vous a déjà dit rappelle-moi
benito ça m'excite
même berlusconi non mais je ne suis pas
du tout le genre de berlusconi ça alors
je suis sur ce point parce que dit il il
aime il est très belle fille d'ailleurs
italienne très traditionnelle c'est là
la belle italienne bien pulpeuse et des
poils sous les bras et on s'était pas du
tout moi je suis pas du tout son genre
du tout
est-ce que vous ai déjà dit elle mais
c'est pas mes couilles ça comment tu l'a
connu à mende à toi amanda gelé connu un
jour au flore est arrivé avec 1 1
philippe c'est vrai et vous pouvez
surveiller tous les gentils rentrée qui
sont clés c'était ou ta place exactement
ma place à droite à gauche quand on
rentre à la plata gauche visite passer
devant lui pour aller aux toilettes au
monté oui surveille tous voulaient pas
besta je voulais pas mettre avec les
folles du premier moi j'adorais pas
sachez que gerald si son apparence qu'il
habitait place sur 100 m
oui petit appart en délicieux et nous a
dit avec un la bible écouter on va aller
en vacances à saint tropez chelou une
grande maison va tous aller en vacances
et alors nous voilà tous partis à saint
tropez avec thierry le luron et des tas
de gens tous dans cette grande maison
c'était génial j'ai c'est génial aller
voilà oui c'est rigolo et moi c'était ma
grande période disco j'avais des
journalistes allemands qui connaît pas
et qui me disais oh mais c'est à vous
cette maison dix huit mois c'est la mois
et années mais qui sont tous ces gens en
montrant gerra le luron et cm2 rester
personnel
en faire sauter il ya une photo qui est
sorti d'ennuis une page entière on voit
le luron couché au bord de la piscine le
dit mon cuisinier en valeur sans mechâal
mon chauffeur est apparemment le luron
l'a très mal pris ce week-end et furieux
dit quand même allés gonfler et à gober
tu sais à propos du flou on dira jamais
assez comment le floor a été mais
l'épicentre de cette vie alors le
déplore c'était indispensable
jusqu'aujourd'hui je crois qu'on se rend
pas bien compte 250 vous visiez c'est
bien tous les soirs moi j'ai des enfants
je suis allé aux 60 g pas quitter le
flanc jusqu'à chez nous pour charmer
valentino alors j'ai rencontré tout le
monde au flanc des corrections de ne
rien rater de finale andy tube abonnez
vous mettez un pouce bleus